be careful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi Georgie what a nice boat do you want
it yes please look like a nice boy I bet
you have a lot of friends sweetie but my
brother's my bestest where is he and
then sick I bet I could cheer him up not
give him up
do you want to balloon to Georgie I'm
not supposed to take stuff from
strangers
oh well I'm very wise and see plow okay
very wise yes meet Georgie Georgie meet
penny wise Howie aren't strangers are we
why are you doing in the cellar
Oh storm blew me away blew the whole
circus away in smells are destroyed you
there's peanuts cotton candy hot dogs
[Music]
is that your favorite because they
[Laughter]
going now
without your bow I don't wanna lose it
Georgie Bell's gonna kill you
[Music]
JT Jersey
[Music]
it redid our my grandfather thinks his
town is cursed he says that all the bad
things that happen in this town are
because of one thing and they will thing
that feeds off two people a dairy but it
can't be one thing we all saw something
different maybe or maybe it knows what
scares us most and that's what we see I
saw a leper he he was like a walking
infection but you didn't because it
isn't real none of this is none of this
makes any sense they're all like bad
dreams I don't think so I know the
difference between a bad dream
in real life okay we're all afraid of
something about that right hi rich what
are you afraid of
clothes my grandfather thinks his town
is cursed that all the bad things that
happened in this town or because of one
thing
an evil thing creating Pennywise with
bill skarsgård was very fulfilling he's
unpredictable and there was something
that caught my attention immediately I
wanted to create something unsettling
Shh this feeling that you never know
what's gonna happen when the clown's
around
[Music]
body language and the madness and his
look was completely unnerving
and he successfully kept bill Pennywise
away from the kids as long as possible
we wanted to keep him away because we
wanted the reaction to be real it is
authentic to how kids should be reacting
and that was one of Andy's things in
terms of scaring the kids having them
not know what our Pennywise is going to
look like look that's where it lives the
first time we saw him all together was
the projector scene it got our real
reactions
I was so freaked out
it was terrifying he's just so sporadic
you don't know what he's gonna do he's
up close in your face screaming at you
it's insane like a demonic animal bill
skarsgård is pain wise who did us all
proud of having Stephen King's see
Liverpool it's amazing so I do hope the
fans for the soon
kids have a wider perspective they see
more they believe more they notice more
and in it I wanted to create characters
who still believe everything children
believe and yet not these kids no longer
believe in Santa Claus or the tooth
fairy
but then when the lights are out they're
still afraid that there's something
under the bed this is not your standard
horror movie it's a movie that feels
with friendship and the power of
confronting darkness together our
characters all have certain things about
ourselves that ostracized us from the
rest of the town
they were all bullied so the losers Club
formed and we're like a huge family you
fall in love with the characters and you
really feel close to them
hanging out with us playing sore loser -
I can take that which makes it even more
scarier when these really bad things
start happening to them I saw something
there was this the clown yeah I saw him
too
the losers figure out something's been
haunting the talent they start searching
for friends but you start to realize
that they're searching for something
much bigger
there's not like any time I've ever been
in before people tired
disappear six times the national average
we realized that all the murders in
Derry all the missing children are all
connected look that's where it lives it
is anything that you are ever afraid of
[Music]
this story was a great parable for what
happens when we don't confront our fears
it's summer we're supposed to be having
fun
no offense Phil I don't want to go
missing even those kids are the only
people able to battle this creature
because they're the only ones who still
believe in monsters what happens when
another Georgie goes missing or one of
us
are you just gonna pretend it isn't
happening like everyone else in this
town you have to go on a mission to
fight against evil and secure our
friendship it's what it was it wants to
divide us but shows how when we come
together we can really do this we stated
together all of us a winner it's a
beautiful story of friendship but this
is a Stephen King adaptation so it's
pretty terrifying
you